anytime i feel like anyone ever takes a
chance on themselves
there's a breaking point where you're
like damn did i make a mistake or
you know before things start going the
right way what was that low point for
you during that period
yes so you know so i left because me and
camilla anthony were super close so i'm
like all right so the last four summers
i'd meet lebron i met katie i met james
i met ross
so i kind of knew him i didn't have
relationships with him but i know him
so my god if i leave the knicks i think
i could like start a training business
uh you know so i left the job as health
insurance you know it's it's a whole
you're leaving a job a good job so i
left
and then i'm thinking like right off the
bat i'm gonna be able to
lebron's gonna come to my gym and katie
and didn't work like that right off the
bat you know it took a minute
to it took a little bit and uh
so you know i think like a few months in
middle of the summer i'm like
damn i don't know if i made the right
decision like i really don't know if i
wasn't making any money uh it was it was
it was a struggle
and then that was when i came up with
black ops and i started doing these five
on five games and that kind of like
changed my life like you know put
together these pickup games that
arguably you know some of the greatest
pickup games ever